[Music]
welcome to think fast talk smart a
podcast designed to hone your
communication skills
one of the communication situations that
makes people most uncomfortable and
nervous is when challenged with
objections and concerns
clearly deep thought and active debate
over ideas often helps improve decision
making but the experience of defending
your ideas and proposals is hard and
fraught with potential pitfalls
in this podcast we'll explore ways of
handling objections while remaining cool
collected and credible
i am so looking forward to diving into
this topic with my friend and fellow
lecturer at the gsp bert alper
welcome bert thank you
if you don't mind
or have any objections i'd like to start
by asking you to talk about a time you
were confronted directly with an
objection from an audience member
how did you handle it well i'll give you
a very specific example and it comes up
all the time when you're offering best
practices to
executive clients
or even here at the gsb
someone always raises their hand and
says well i like what you're saying but
that would never work in my company or
that would never work in my weekly
meeting
and as a first step when i get that
pushback
while i want to get defensive i'm trying
to train myself to be more
open to that criticism so the very first
thing that i'll do is i'll acknowledge
that concern is legitimate you're right
there are some situations for which this
rule or this guide or this piece of
information may not be appropriate and i
find that's a quick way of defusing the
situation people want to be acknowledged
they want to be validated
and if you can build a bridge right out
of the gate you're starting off on the
right foot
second thing i'll do
i'll offer them the freedom to adjust as
they seem as they seem necessary so if
it might not work in your particular
environment is there something you could
do that would work in that environment
and the third thing i'll do is i'll push
back a little bit
maybe you haven't tried this in your
weekly meeting and you think it won't
work but until you actually give it a
shot
see what happens and then adjust as
necessary going forward you don't really
know and i might
invite them to try one particular aspect
of the best practices that i've given
them and see if that one fits and if not
okay then we know it doesn't work in
that situation um you're talking about
the approach you take and really
thinking about being open to somebody
else's opinion rather than immediately
getting defensive right and and i think
so many people get defensive right away
even before they get into the situation
they're prepared for battle and i and
and i know that that can restrict the
the interaction and and what's possible
so let's talk a little bit more about
preparation what do you advise people to
do in advance of situations where
objections might be raised what are some
best practices there i think there's
certainly the opportunity to anticipate
where the pushback's going to come
so if you're dealing with any kind of
information that has a contentious
element or maybe even an unfamiliar
element
thinking ahead of time about how that's
going to land with your audience where
you might receive the pushback
and making a strategy ahead of time so
if you're
upending the way the expense reports are
done and you know that the people in
your firm are creatures of habit and
they want to keep doing things the same
old way
how do you anticipate the pushback
you're going to receive and and before
you get into that moment of contention
you've already got a strategy for how
you might
make that a little easier for them to
swallow certainly having those
contingency plans i think can really
help so that when you hear it come in
you've got some ideas about how to
manage it and and that's absolutely good
advice to think about what can i do if
this comes up and perhaps are there ways
to
circumvent or address it in advance so
it helps you prepare for that
now i know when you and i teach about
objection handling we talk about how
objections can be divided into two
categories we talk about emotional
objections and logical objections can
you define
what distinctions are between those two
types and and perhaps give some examples
as long as you and i have been talking
about this we've gone back and forth on
that and i think it is a fascinating way
of breaking down skepticism or
objections in conversations
the
age-old cliche of the forest and the
trees i find is really valuable here
yeah often
the more logical concerns or objections
are getting down to that individual tree
level
the specific point about the quarterly
budget not accommodating any new
expenses something very particular
that's rubbing them the wrong way and
they've got to get that that issue out
there
on the flip side the emotional
objections tend to be
of the forest view and they might not be
able to see or even put a label on the
concern they're having it's just not
sitting well with them and and you'll
often hear people say i can't put a
finger on it i don't know what it is
that's not working for me but something
in here isn't working for me so if
thinking about
individual
trees versus the entire forest for me
breaks down the logical versus the
emotional reactions
it strikes me that in preparing for
these kind of interactions having a
stockpile of specific statistics or
specific approaches to expand and extend
a point would be really helpful to to be
ready with this different information so
you're not caught off guard right away
and that's where your preparation is so
valuable you start to anticipate where
the skepticism might come
and how you're going to handle it and
there might be three or four different
approaches that you've mapped out to
each of those specific objections but
time and circumstance time in audience
will determine which uh response you
might apply to that particular pushback
absolutely so so yet another thing to
put into the preparation category
you know one of the things that we teach
and we talk a lot about bird is this
notion of how to handle objections
through reframing
how does reframing work when it comes to
handling skepticism and objections
i think of reframing as a way of giving
yourself the speaker or the
information deliverer
room to maneuver
and
in the simplest terms you're giving your
chan yourself a chance to respond to the
objection without admitting defeat
and sometimes you have to change the way
we're talking about something in order
to be able to address the issue without
saying yeah you're right this is a
terrible idea
yeah i see this all the time in the in
the work i do with clients as well as
with the students so for example if
somebody is being pressed why a certain
feature isn't in a product
and you know that that feature is not
coming now or maybe ever it's possible
to reframe that to be a broader
discussion about how do we prioritize
feature set and as a result of that
discussion you can then come back and
address the key issue
i think what's so critical here and i
know you and i agree on this is whenever
you reframe a discussion you're not
becoming a politician and just talking
about what you wanted to talk about
you're addressing the issue at a dif in
a different way at a different level and
you always have to come back to what the
challenge or question or skepticism is
about that is such a crucial point
you have to put yourself in the other
person's shoes
if you were the one who had the
objection
and someone
took a reframe too far and started
answering a different question
how would that make you feel you would
feel
either unappreciated or unheard
or it might even make you think less of
the person who's trying to communicate
in the first place because they didn't
seem like they were able to manage your
question so your point about coming back
to the core issue is critical if you
don't answer the question at some level
you're missing
the whole point and your audience is
going to see that as a weakness or as a
missed opportunity certainly and i think
part again going back to preparation is
you can begin to think about these
reframes in advance so i know that
questions about feature set can be
talked about in terms of priority i know
if somebody brings up a question about
pricing i can reframe that as a question
about value so having these ideas in
mind in advance again can help you if
and when that arises absolutely
now i want to talk a bit about
paraphrasing because as powerful as
reframing is i think paraphrasing is
really critical for handling objections
and skepticism in the moment well i
think the first thing that paraphrasing
does is establishes what are we really
talking about so if someone raises an
issue and you may or may not know
exactly what they're concerned about by
putting the paraphrase into the
conversation
either overtly saying i just want to
make sure i'm clear on this or tacitly
saying i just want to make sure i'm
clear on this you're establishing
that we're talking about the same issue
and audiences
particularly skeptical audiences
enjoy
the or appreciate the effort to to make
sure that you're on the same
topic so you've established a bit of an
empathetic connection with them just by
trying to to clear the air
paraphrasing also allows you to reframe
so you can put your words on top of
their words and if you do it skillfully
enough
if you've had enough time to prepare
they might allow you the freedom to
change it from a question about pricing
to a question about value and that's a
subtle reframe
in the form of a paraphrase
i think where people tend to get a
little into the danger zone here is if
you push the paraphrase too far
and now it's no longer the same topic
then you'll get the objector digging in
his or her heels even further because
they feel like you're trying to skirt
the issue so the paraphrase needs to be
as accurate as you can make it
but you can adjust
the frame of reference a little bit in
that paraphrase yeah and i think
paraphrasing is something that people
have to understand is not this big thing
that you always have to say so what i
hear you saying is and then there's a
repetition you can extract just some key
ideas or phrases
and go from there so it allows you
a way to
take the floor to do some reframing to
do the validation you're talking about
as well as to really help yourself
formulate your thoughts along the way
i do want to bring up this notion of
emotion since emotion is around i
believe and i get i'm curious to get
your thoughts on this that acknowledging
the emotion without naming it is
critical to do early in the paraphrase
so if somebody comes at you with a lot
of heat you know maybe they're angry
maybe they're passionate to rather than
to say oh i hear your anger and then the
person well really i'm frustrated now
we're arguing over their emotional state
i think just to say hey i hear there's a
lot of passion here
and then move forward
acknowledges that emotion puts it out
there because everybody hears it
and for you to ignore it i think puts
you at a disadvantage i'm curious your
thoughts i really like that uh i'm as
soon as you started talking about the uh
i hear that you're angry example
i'm
you know i buy products i'm a consumer
in addition to being a coach
when i get a bad experience in the the
outside world and i talk to the customer
service rep and they say oh i i i feel
your anger or i'm sorry that you feel so
angry
that does not make me feel any better
the acknowledgement of my anger doesn't
make me feel any better if they were to
say
this is really important to you
and therefore it's really important to
me
wow it's a powerful shift now i feel
like you as the customer service person
are really taking how significant this
is in my life
right
as we end i like to ask people the same
three questions to get their ideas
reflections thoughts on
communication in general so if you're
ready are you ready bert i hope so okay
there we go
um i'd like to ask you the same three
questions
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you've ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would that
advice be
i can only choose one phrase
five to seven words
it's not what you want to say
it's what they need to hear
i didn't count the number of words but i
i i think you're close but so important
and it really gets back to that notion
of framing that we talked about doesn't
it and really understanding what's
needed in the moment
who's a communicator that you admire and
why
i've been
referencing oprah winfrey a lot these
days i watched her acceptance of the
cecil b demille award at the golden
globes a few years ago
and i am blown away by her ability to
sound
authentic and sincere she's wonderful at
that
but to vary the the tone and the
intention that she's able to achieve in
an authentic way
so she can be
endearing and sweet and very lovable and
she can be very strong and powerful and
authoritative
authentically
in the same speech
and that is an incredible range of
emotion it's a incredible range of vocal
quality
and she backs it all up with very
powerful content that has specific
examples that are relatable that are
familiar and that really do drive her
point home
well said for sure
so last and certainly not least what are
the first three ingredients that go into
a successful communication recipe
that's a great question
i'm gonna go alliterative on you well i
like alliteration
i'm gonna say passion
preparation
and personality
i want you to bring all the enthusiasm
that you have for the topic i want you
to prepare
in advance so that you know what your
audience
needs and wants
and i want you to bring your own
personal style and flair to whatever
conversation you're having
let me try a little alliteration with
you
great gift you've given all of us as we
go about our communication thank you so
much for sharing your insights not just
about communication but how to handle
challenges objections and skepticism
you know bert this topic is so critical
to success we all
need to be able to
share our opinions and our ideas but
also handle those ideas when they get
challenged when people
bring up alternative points of view we
see this happening not just in our work
lives and our personal lives but we see
it happening in society in general the
ability to
approach objection in an open way to
foster dialogue rather than to foster
dissent is so critical i really
appreciate the insights you shared and i
hope all of us can take advantage of
some of these tools
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
produced by stanford university's
graduate school of business
for more information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu
or subscribe to our show wherever you
get your podcasts finally find us on
social media at stanford.gsb